today i want to introduce
my contract with the british people
this will be a solemn agreement
about what this country needs and how a
good government should conduct itself
i'm well aware
that just because the tories lose the
public's trust
it doesn't mean that labour simply
inherits it
trust has to be earned
i am confident but not complacent about
the task ahead
so the very first clause in the contract
is a binding commitment
about decency
and standards in public life
of course those standards already exist
they're known as the nolan principles
selflessness
integrity
objectivity
accountability
openness
honesty
and leadership
so my solemn promise to you will be
always to run a government
that honors these principles
i have a very clear idea of what a
labour government would look like
and in 2022 i want to take my plans to
the british people
now i've spent a career working as a
lawyer
so you're probably expecting about a
thousand clauses seven appendices a list
of definitions
well my contract
won't be anything like that
it will be a contract based on three
simple principles
security
prosperity
and respect
these are living principles and that's
why in the coming months i'll hold a
series of events around the country to
persuade people to sign up
to this new britain that we can create
together
the first term in the contract is
security
everyone has the basic right to feel
safe in their own community
we all need to know that the nhs is
there
for us when we need it
and that if we work hard we should also
have a right to job security
the second term in the contract is
prosperity
everyone should have the opportunity to
thrive
to realize our ambitions and make a good
life for ourselves
to have the skills we need to prosper
and then there is a third term in my
contract
respect
is a less obvious political virtue than
security on prosperity
but it's every bit as important
everyone has the right to live in places
we care for
to have our lives and ambitions taken
seriously
to be valued for who we are
and what we do
i want to create a contract defined by
security prosperity and respect
to create a contract for a government
worthy of the fine nation in which we
live
the labour party is a deeply patriotic
party
kia hardy once said that british
socialism must wear a local guard
he meant
that british socialism was rooted in the
everyday concerns of working people
the titans of 1945 were elected to power
on the votes of the d-mob servicemen and
women
that government took the spirit of
collective sacrifice generated by the
war and turned it into the national
health service for which we are so
thankful today
it was a patriotic government
which understood the importance of
national defence which created nato
the alliance that has preserved the
peace in europe ever since
and gave this country its independent
nuclear deterrent
the 1945 labour government
laid the foundations for the end of
empire and the beginning of the modern
commonwealth
under wilson the open university
extended higher education
the race relations act of 1965
prohibited racial discrimination
barbara castle's equal pay act was a
watershed moment in the fight for gender
equality
the blair government introduced a
national minimum wage and repaired the
public services that had been neglected
under the tories
when i reflect
on previous labor governments
i have two thoughts
the first is
what a record we have
these three chapters of change atlee
wilson and blair
made britain a better country
we must be the people
who write the fourth chapter
the people who create a new britain in
the 21st century
and second
nobody could look on that record
and say that labor is not a patriotic
party
those labor governments had the ambition
to build a society in which everyone can
contribute
and everyone is valued
to extend security prosperity and
respect to all
this is the tradition we embrace
and the mission we inherit
the first duty of government is the
security of its citizens i was once the
country's leading prosecutor
crime and anti-social behavior are
issues that matter to me personally i've
seen too many victims of crime most of
them not at all well off
not to know
that security
is a matter of social justice
that's why labour will provide crime
prevention teams in every neighborhood
new police hubs will be visible in every
community
we will introduce a new tough approach
to closing down drug dens with new
powers for local police and local
authorities
security also means knowing that the nhs
is there for you when you need it
and i'll be setting out a long-term plan
to show how a labour government will
shift the emphasis from emergency care
to preventing people getting sick in the
first place
we will also ensure that people feel
more secure at work
by introducing the new protections for
workers that angela rainer announced at
our conference last year
for example one of the things the
pandemic has taught us
is that everyone needs decent pay when
they're sick
but that isn't the case for millions of
british workers
i know of care workers
looking after vulnerable people who
can't afford to be ill
because they won't get paid
that's not only unfair on them
it's unsafe for the country and a labor
government will fix it
and a labor britain must be a prosperous
nation
this country needs an industrial
strategy to improve our productivity to
ensure that we buy make and sell more in
britain and to revive the places that
made britain wealthy
so for example at our conference we
pledged an extra 28 billion pounds a
year in capital investment to combat
climate change to create the next
generation of jobs and to inspire
innovation for a clean future
and this promises a future to places
that were once defined by what they made
let me give you a flavor of what i think
might be possible
not long ago i visited the humber gas
works
the gas they stored
helped to keep the prices low
but the government let it close in 2017
and you've seen what's happened to gas
prices since
but the workers there are not looking to
the past
they're convinced that with the right
investment and government support
the humber could become a hub for the
production of hydrogen
these workers want to make a historic
contribution to combating the climate
crisis
they want to be in the vanguard of the
next industrial revolution
all they need
is a government that shares their
ambition and runs with it of all the
things boris johnson has done
the one that truly astonishes me was
that a prime minister
who claims to be interested in leveling
up
tore up their own industrial strategy
what an extraordinary act of self-harm
labor would create a hundred thousand
new startup businesses
and new hubs of excellence building on
existing strengths
such as video gaming in dundee
by a farmer in cambridgeshire
and here in birmingham there's brando
which began life as a pen manufacturer
and which now produces plates used in
hydrogen fuel cells a technology that
could help to power lorries to have new
zero emissions
in each of these examples new technology
is being used imaginatively to create
prosperity
but that prosperous future is only
possible
if we equip our people properly
this country has always made a
world-class offer
to a small section of society
and a substandard offer to those who do
not take the academic course
so it'll be a vital clause in my
contract with the british people and the
task for my skills advisory council
to ensure that the next generation of
students
is ready for work
and ready for life
i believe passionately that everyone has
the right to be treated with respect
no places should be left behind
and nobody should be treated as if they
don't matter
and i know this can happen
i saw it with my dad
my dad always felt undervalued because
he worked in a factory
he felt people look down on him
and he wasn't wrong about that
people have their dignity
and it needs to be respected
i want to live in a country in which
crucial skills are valued in which
everyone is respected for what they
contribute
and in britain we make and we will
always play by the rules
i regard the rule of law as one of the
things that makes britain great
due process treating institutions with
respect
the integrity of british justice has
always been the envy of the world
and it's always been a big part in our
economic success
a good reason to do business in britain
is that you know a contract will be
respected
and that respect underwrites your
investment
that's why doing the right thing that
right things in the right way matters
as much as doing the right things
and this year i will set out what i mean
by respect what it demands of government
and what it demands of all of us
because any successful contract
is a two-way deal
you can expect access to high quality
healthcare
but there will be zero tolerance of
abuse towards nhs staff
you can expect the opportunity to
acquire new skills
but you will be expected to work hard
and do your bit
you can expect better neighborhood
policing
but you will be expected to behave like
good neighbors in your own community too